- Well, you're in one of
the big movies this summer,
'The Suicide Squad', are you so stoked?
- Oh my god, I'm really excited.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Really excited.
I love the posters,
oh look they are.
- I-
- Look how good they are look.
- I'm so exci- I'm into
like anything like this.
- It's really fun.
- Like any super, like group,
I'm into anything like this.
Were you as a kid?
- I was. I-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Since I was a little
kid, I loved comic books.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was actually really
really blessed that it was
able to do a Marvel film
which is New Mutants.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- A while ago.
And now
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Suicide Squad, which is
DC, which for a nerd kid,
that I was.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's been a dream.
- Those are different.
- Yeah.
- Completely different. I
really, really loved it.
Now, and this one, I think the
fans are really gonna love it
because James Gunn, the
director, he's so brilliant.
He directed, um Guardians of the Galaxy.
- Yeah, which I love.
- I love it.
And it's so much fun.
There's so much laugh in it,
even though there's explosions
and all the craziness.
- The comedy in those
films are always my fav-
it's cause the moments were,
that's the best kind of comedy.
- Just from the trailer,
you're going to see
the vibe of the film.
It's really powerful.
- Aw, I'm so stoked for you.